we've been here in Westminster is just
be fishing he's professor of politics at
brunel university and joins us from New
York Angela McLaren thank you both for
being with us and Angelo it obviously
works in America attack ads it does work
in America but Adam this is nothing new
back in when LBJ was running against
Goldwater LBJ do today Ziad and all he
did was a countdown and saying in
essence that if you'll let Goldwater
we're going to go to war so it's nothing
new in America is it the right type of
politics no but does it work yes it does
and on the scale of good attacks what do
you think of calling someone a
backstabber the bottom line is this I'm
not for negative campaigning what I'm
for is people actually knowing the facts
so whether it's a backstabber or calling
President Obama Muslim and then you had
some people saying that he wasn't even
born in America you see that president
obama won against mitt romney so
apparently some people don't really
believe in that but if you can define
your opponent before your opponent finds
himself then you will have a victory I
mean that is interesting about this
charge isn't it professor Fisher because
everyone knows the story of the
miliband's is one of the few things
people do know about Ed Miliband yet The
Times has got a pole for you gov where
which is just out and it shows that 64%
think it was perfectly reasonable for
head Miliband to run against his brother
so both dirty tactics and possibly not
very effective well no are not very
effective at all i think it seems to be
a bit of an own goal for the
conservatives the issue in question the
trident it's a perfectly reasonable one
to raise and and draw blue water between
between the parties but by calling
another politician of backstabber it may
go down well in the united states but i
think the evidence we have in this
country is that it can be
counterproductive of course some people
might say that if you want to be a
successful politician Angela you've got
to be quite nasty capable of stabbing
the odd back well you're you're talking
to a lady that ran for office in
Mississippi for Congress and I did not
do negative campaigning actually I told
the truth about my opponent my opponent
I'll raise
five hundred thousand dollars AC I'm not
in Congress a maxilla political analysts
unfortunately mudslinging here in
America works for not only bet is
whoever can raise the most money but as
if you can raise a lot of money at them
then you can pay for a commercial time
and also grassroots campaign and get out
the vote campaigns well that's an
interesting point because in this
campaign we know that the Conservatives
have more money than any of the other
parties and we also know while it's
restricted what they can spend on what
they can say on television what the
concern billboards we are seeing a lot
of graphics online being tweeted around
and sent around some of them with
official from all the parties but
particularly the conservative absolutely
the interesting thing is that that has
really developed this election whether
or not it makes a difference remains to
be seen our analysis of the last
campaign for example showed that
although the Conservatives have a
significant financial advantage both a
constituency level and at national level
labor and the Liberal Democrats
grassroots campaigning had more effect
on the amount of seats that they won so
all of those things help but at our
evidence to date suggests that voters
respond better to the traditional
doorstep style campaigning and of course
laborer talking about these four million
conversations and say they're having
more of those than a conservatives what
about labour saying that they're not
going to use pictures of their opponents
in their advertisements do you get any
points of being high-minded or claiming
to be high-minded well I think you can
be high-minded or clear at least claim
to be high-minded it wouldn't surprise
me if they did have pictures of other
politicians and I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I mean the
Liberal Democrats for example in 2005
made a great play of showing lots of
pictures of Tony Blair because it tended
to boost their polling particularly
around the issue of Iraq I think what's
different about this is that it's a
personal attack on an individual which
as we saw in 2005 when Michael Howard
call Tony Blair a liar that tends to go
down badly with the electorate do you
think answer that people tend to go
negative when they haven't got much
positive to say I think that it's both
sides
whether you have something positive to
say when you're actually debating in the
primary process here in America or when
you're running and in the real general
election but you were talking about your
labor organizations they're here in
America labor organizations give a lot
of money to politicians to help them run
negative ads it's on both sides you have
conservatives that also raise a lot of
money to run negative is so here in
America is a bit different then they're
the only thing that I can say that's
equal is when you have the cash you can
get your message out clearer and as a
conservative American do you think that
the United States has bothered one way
or another whether Britain renews its
nuclear deterrent which of course would
be primarily supplied by America listen
the thing is this as a conservative I'm
about the issues I'm about less
government and I'm not for negative
campaigning so I'm hopeful in this
election next year 2016 which I think
that Jeb Bush is going to be the nominee
on the Republican side Hillary Clinton
is going to be the nominee on the
Democratic side then we can have a clean
Campaign unlike we had in 2012 do you
think we should keep a nuclear weapon
and a nuclear deterrent in this country
say again should we keep nuclear weapons
in this country this is what sparked off
this route yes yes yes and yes the
bottom line is you need to protect your
homeland because if you can't protect
your homeland you won't have a homeland
to live in so yes we should keep nuclear
weapons our people worried you think
about the nuclear deterrent I mean the
polls are fairly divided aren't they
it's not an issue that tends to be at
the top of people's concerns those are
usually bread-and-butter issues like the
economy like education like health but
this sort of thing will matter to people
it mattered in 87 for example when the
conservatives majored on Labour's
nuclear policy which would seem to be a
vote loser for labor back then and do
you okay you got a strong view on the
nuclear deterrent do you have a strong
view on our election are you are you
bothered who wins this election look all
I can say is this p
just need to get out and they need to
vote their conscience they need to vote
for who they think is the best and I
wish in a way we were more like you guys
here in America because a lot of times
people make miss informed decisions when
they go to the polls on television
commercials on the media instead of
reading and finding about the candidate
themselves okay thank you both very much
indeed joining us thank you